[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind sie auch Rudi Zahne für
den Sport hallo schönen guten Abend wir
haben unter anderem diese Themen für Sie
und prüft taurus-lieferung die Debatte
und deutsche Lenkflugkörper für die
Ukraine nimmt Fahrt auf
trotz des Krieges und aller Sanktionen
Russland startet eine Mondmission und
will dort als Erster am Südpol sein
und Überraschung im Viertelfinale
Schweden wirft die hochgelobten
Japanerinnen durch einen 2:1 Sieg aus
der WM
[Musik]
seit Wochen bittet die Ukraine
Deutschland um Waffen des Typs Taurus
bislang zögert der Bundeskanzler auch
aus Sorge vor einer weiteren Eskalation
die Bundesregierung prüft allerdings
schon Lieferungen aus Beständen der
Bundeswehr
der gut fünf Meter lange Taurus startet
von einem Flugzeug aus Stückpreis knapp
eine Million Euro der Lenkflugkörper
kann mit Hilfe von Sensoren und
Navigationssystemen Ziele in weiter
Entfernung punktgenau treffen und Taurus
hat einen eigenen Jet-Antrieb damit kann
er auch unterhalb des feindlichen Radars
fliegen und rund 500 km zurücklegen
genau um diese Reichweite geht es in der
aktuellen Debatte Andreas Huppert
irgendwo im ukrainischen Kriegsgebiet
Aufnahmen des russischen Militärs zeigen
Angriffe auf Verteidigungsstellungen der
Frontverlauf Stock keine Seite scheint
dabei momentan Erfolge zu erzielen auch
deshalb erhofft sich die Ukraine mehr
modernes Kriegsgerät das Deutsch
schwedische System Taurus steht ganz
oben auf der Liste durch die große
Reichweite könnte die Ukraine mit Taurus
auch russisches Territorium angreifen
es ist eine Frage des Vertrauens in die
Ukraine dass sie die Ziele bekämpft die
nötig sind und das bedeutet ein
Abschneiden der russischen
Versorgungslinien von der Krim das kann
Taurus viel besser als alles andere der
Kanzler hält sich bislang bedeckt von
ihm noch keine Ansage Teile seiner
Partei wollen Taurus lieber nicht
liefern Besonderheit ist glaube ich
besonders gefragt wir haben nämlich
nicht nur die das Interesse die Ukraine
war ja Verteidigung unterstützen das tun
wir sondern darüber hinaus auch
Eskalation zu vermeiden darauf zu achten
dass wir nicht hineingezogen werden
wieder als NATO noch als Deutschland
diskutiert wird auch ob man Taurus in
einer Variante abgibt bei der die
Reichweite technisch eingeschränkt wird
Militärexperten halten das für unsinnig
das wird ja letztendlich nicht verboten
gestartet sondern von einem fliegenden
Waffensystem wie will ich denn eine F16
oder irgendwas daran hindern mich
irgendwo in den Luftraum zu bewegen und
von dort abzuschließen im ZDF Interview
hat heute die stellvertretende
ukrainische Verteidigungsministerin
zugesagt Taurus nur auf ukrainischen
Territorium einsetzen
in diesem Krieg akzeptiert die Ukraine
die Normen des internationalen Rechts
wie Kriege zu führen sind das bedeutet
dass die Ukraine sich nur auf ihren
Territorium verteidigt unter
strategisches Ziel ist die Befreiung
unserer von den Russen besetzten Gebiete
ob eine deutsche Zustimmung für die
Taurus Lieferung kommt ist offen sicher
ist der Krieg in der Ukraine geht weiter
mehr zur taurusdebatte gibt es bei ZDF
heute live dort antwortet ab 19.30 Uhr
der Militärexperte Ralf Thiele auch auf
Ihre Fragen zu sehen in der heute App
und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
eine neue Mondmission mitten im Krieg
damit will Moskau zeigen dass es trotz
der westlichen Sanktionen in der Lage
ist wissenschaftliche Großprojekte
durchzuziehen zum ersten Mal seit einem
halben Jahrhundert ist aus Russland
wieder eine sonderrichtung Mond
gestartet das soll an die früheren
Erfolge der raumfahrtnation anknüpfen
Armin
es ist zehn nach neun Ortszeit als die
Rakete startet vom neu gebauten
Weltraumbahnhof was tot Schnee im fernen
Osten des Landes allen westlichen
Sanktionen zum Trotz macht sich Russland
nach fast 50 Jahren wieder auf die Reise
zurück zum Mond
lassen sie uns ehrlich sein die Flüge
zum Mond hatten doch immer eine
politische Komponente
nun wer da der erste ist der ist
sozusagen besser als jene die zweiten
sind
zweimal nimmt Luna 25 Schwung rund um
die Erde und macht sich dann auf den Weg
Richtung Mond schwenkt nach etwa vier
Tagen auf dessen Umlaufbahn ein landen
soll sie in der wenig erforschten
Südpolregion die liegt immer im Schatten
ist sehr uneben und voller Krater sechs
Tage nehmen sich die Russen Zeit um den
besten Landepunkt zu finden
wir suchen einen neuen Landeplatz wo
niemand je gewesen ist ich hoffe dass
wir die ersten dort sein werden
12 April 1961 mit dem großen Juri
Gagarin schickt die Sowjetunion den
ersten Menschen ins All und schreibt
Geschichte daran erinnert auch Präsident
Putin am Jahrestag als er nach dem Ende
der Zusammenarbeit mit den Europäern
große Ziele verkündet für das Jahr 2014
wir wollen eine eigene Raumstation als
Außenposten unseres Landes im All doch
all die irdischen Herausforderungen
dürfen wir trotzdem nicht vergessen
[Musik]
in etwa 10 Tagen soll die Sonne auf dem
Mond landen in Zeiten größter
Verunsicherung sucht Putins Reich die
Vergewisserung seiner selbst in den
unendlichen Weiten des Weltraums
Gouverneur spricht von der wohl
schlimmsten Katastrophe in seinem
Bundesstaat mindestens 55 Menschen
starben bei den verheerenden Bränden die
Inselgruppe liegt vom amerikanischen
Festland rund fünf Flugstunden entfernt
im Pazifik besonders betroffen ist Maui
die zweitgrößte Insel dort haben die
Flammen die alte hawaiianische
Königstadt Lahaina fast vollständig
zerstört nun beginnt die Suche nach
Vermissten und das Bergen der Toten
David sauer
juli Landi und ihre Familie an Ihrem
Haus und Grundstück oder dem was davon
übrig ist bislang wussten sie nicht
steht ihr Haus noch leben die Nachbar
es ist das erste Mal dass wir
zurückkommen und wissen dass unser Haus
abgebrannt ist in den letzten Tagen
haben wir nichts erfahren es gab keine
Information
Spuren dessen was vor dem Inferno mal
Alltagswelt war in Minuten nahm das
Feuer sich hier alles mehr als 1700
Heime und vor allem viele Menschen leben
kennen die Olufsen hat alles verloren
aber sie lebt ihre Nachbarn haben es
nicht geschafft
Menschen gefunden die sich gegenseitig
festhielten das Feuer hat sie umzingelt
bevor sie es rausschafften
die Uferpromenade auf der Flucht vor den
Flammen mussten viele ihre Autos
zurücklassen praktisch kein Gebäude ist
mehr bewohnbar auf vielen hundert Metern
bleiben nur häuserskelette und glimmende
Asche um Hilfe zu erleichtern hat das
Weiße Haus in Katastrophenfall
ausgerufen
wir stellen Ressourcen des Bundes bereit
um schnell vor Ort zu sein und die Hilfe
zu unterstützen die für den Wiederaufbau
nötig ist und zur Unterstützung der
Menschen vor Ort
wem nichts geblieben ist der findet in
Notunterkünften Zuflucht hier gibt es
zumindest Wasser Essen decken nicht ganz
Maui ist betroffen und der Zusammenhalt
nach der Katastrophe ist groß wir helfen
kann bringt es hier denen die es
brauchen
die Ermittlungen gegen seinen Sohn
Hunter werden für den amerikanischen
Präsidenten Joe Biden möglicherweise zu
einem größeren Problem im Wahlkampf das
Justizministerium hat jetzt einen
Sonderermittler eingesetzt eigentlich
geht es in den laufenden Ermittlungen
gegen Hand der beiden um
Steuerhinterziehung und illegalen Waffen
Besitz die oppositionellen Republikaner
werfen ihm auch vor die wichtige
Stellung seines Vaters in der
Vergangenheit für Geschäfte unter
anderem in der Ukraine und in China
ausgenutzt zu haben
jetzt nach Großbritannien das staatliche
Gesundheitssystem dort ist chronisch
unterfinanziert und unterbesetzt das
schafft Frust bei Beschäftigten und
Patienten denn
7,6 Millionen Menschen stehen auf der
Warteliste für eine Routinebehandlung im
Krankenhaus von ihnen warten rund
380.000 schon länger als ein Jahr und
jetzt streiken auch noch die
Assistenzärzte ihr Anfangsgehalt liegt
umgerechnet bei 2.500 Euro im Monat ihre
Forderung 35% mehr glückwalport
berichtet
sie wollen eine faire Bezahlung es ist
bereits der fünfte Streik der
Assistenzärztinnen und Ärzte seit März
dieses Jahres aufgeben wollen sie erst
wenn ihre Forderung nach 35% mehr Gehalt
erfüllt ist
[Musik]
in Irland sind die Ärzte Gehälter
doppelt so hoch wie hier in England
der Ärzte Streik ist nur ein sichtbares
Zeichen für die vielen Probleme im
staatlichen Gesundheitsdienst nhls
chronische Überbelastung teils marode
Infrastruktur mangelnde Finanzierung der
brexit so hatte Ex-Premier Johnson
versprochen werde mehr Geld für den nhls
bringen das war nicht der Fall derzeit
sind allein 8.700 Arztstellen und 43.000
pflegejobs unbesetzt der
Gesundheitsminister benimmt Tarif Streit
nicht nachgeben 8,8% hat er angeboten
bei einer Inflationsrate von 8% gerade
ausreichend um keine real lungenverluste
hinzunehmen
wir haben ein faires Angebot
unterbreitet und alle Empfehlungen der
unabhängigen gehaltskommission
übernommen die Gewerkschaft sollte die
Streiks jetzt beenden
in der Bevölkerung gibt es mehrheitlich
Unterstützung für eine bessere
Ausstattung des nhls und damit auch für
höhere Gehälter des Ärzte Personals
kritisiert werden jahrelange
Budget-Kürzungen der konservativen
Regierungen
werden die Wartelisten länger sie lassen
den NHL kommen und fördern amerikanische
Gesundheitskonzern
Geld für Kriege dann sollen sie auch
Geld für die Ärzte finden ganz einfach
die wiederkehrenden Streiks haben
bislang Kosten von umgerechnet mehr als
einer Milliarde Euro verursacht vier
Tage soll der Ausstand diesmal dauern
eine Einigung ist nicht in Sicht
egal ob Bier Absatz oder Geburten das
Statistische Bundesamt liefert für fast
jeden Bereich Zahlen es erfasst wie
viele Geringverdiener es gibt wie stark
die Preise steigen wer nach Deutschland
kommt gerade in Zeiten von Fake News
eine extrem wichtige Quelle zum 75
Geburtstag heute kam auch der
Bundeskanzler Peter Theißen berichtet
die Elektronen Gehirne des Statistischen
Bundesamtes errechnen die sozialen
Leistungen unserer Wirtschaft Daten und
Fakten sammeln damals wie heute die
Aufgabe des Statistischen Bundesamtes in
Wiesbaden ich glaube dass wir heute
Daten besser erklären müssen als vor 20
oder 30 Jahren weil durch die Diskussion
in den sozialen Medien auch häufiger
Interpretationen gemacht werden die
nicht zutreffen sind viele dieser Daten
wie etwa die Bevölkerungsentwicklung
sind wichtige Grundlage für politisches
Handeln heute machte sich der
Bundeskanzler ein Bild vor Ort
Demokratie lebt davon dass wir wissen
wie ist es denn nun wirklich in unserem
Land und deshalb ist es schon ein Stück
Rationalität dass wir bekommen wenn wir
die Daten des Statistischen Bundesamtes
haben das hilft dann auch gegen Fake
News 75 Jahre ist die Statistikbehörde
alt in den 50er Jahren war das Daten
sammeln und verarbeiten noch richtige
Handarbeit die Lochkarte als technisches
Hilfsmittel heute sind die Abläufe
wesentlich komplexer so durchforstet
Christian laudo das Internet um die
Inflationsrate bestimmen zu helfen nicht
weniger als eine Million Artikel hat er
im Blick also die Internetpreise die
machen rund 11 % der Inflationsrate aus
die Internetpreise sind sehr volatil und
entsprechend muss man sehr viel
abgreifen um dann eine präsentativen
Preis zu erhalten übrigens jeder kann
auf der Seite des Statistischen
Bundesamtes auch seine persönliche
Inflationsrate berechnen die variiert
stark zum Beispiel je nachdem was für
eine Art von Heizung im Haus ist oder ob
man ein Auto hat
wenn junge Leute sich für ein
freiwilliges soziales oder ökologisches
Jahr entscheiden dann ist das für die
Gesellschaft und für die Entwicklung der
Jugendlichen ein echter gewinnen sie
bekommen dafür maximal 438 € im Monat im
kommenden Jahr will die Bundesregierung
genau bei diesen Freiwilligendiensten
sparen Sozialverbände sind empört
der Waldkindergarten in Bonn ein
Paradies für die Kleinen und eine
wichtige Erfahrung für Verena Pupp die
17-jährige leistet hier ihr FSJ ein
freiwilliges soziales Jahr vor 11
Monaten entschied sie sich für diesen
Schritt sie fände es nicht gut wenn
künftig Geld gekürzt wurde wir haben ja
als junge Generation sowieso schon voll
viel verpasst durch Corona viele
Praktika sind ins Wasser gefallen das
war jetzt auch meine allererste
Erfahrung im Arbeitsleben und ich finde
das einfach schade dass man da nicht
mehr gefördert wird weil das auch total
wichtig ist für die Charakterbildung
fast 100.000 junge Menschen leisten in
Deutschland Freiwilligendienst in Kitas
Schulen oder Altenheimen sozialverbände
warnen wenn hier 113 Millionen Euro
eingespart werden müssten viele künftig
jede vierte Stelle weg hinzukommt
Freiwilligendienste helfen uns ganz akut
bei der Bekämpfung des Fachkräftemangels
denn jeder zweite freiwillige geht mal
bei uns in die Ausbildung oder macht ein
Studium im sozialen Bereich und das ist
wirklich ein Pfund
hunderttausende haben eine Petition
unterschrieben in der sie die Rücknahme
der Kürzungen fordern die zuständige
Bundesfamilienministerin äußert sich nur
schriftlich
auch für das Bundesministerium für
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend
gelten daher strikte Sparvorgaben die
Spielräume verengen sich dadurch
deutlich
Verena Pub hat durch das soziale
Engagement ihren Berufswunsch gefunden
sie möchte Försterin werden
die Idee war so einfach wie genial warum
nicht sowas wie die Maschinenhalle der
Zeche Zollern für kulturnutzen
schließlich gibt es im Ruhrgebiet
reichlich davon also wurde vor 21 Jahren
die Ruhe Triennale ins Leben gerufen
jetzt ist es wieder soweit bis zum 23
September glänzt das Ruhrgebiet mit
schauspieltanz und Musik aus der ganzen
Welt Kerstin Edinger war da
auch dieses ungewöhnliche Projekt namens
Skatepark ist bei der diesjährigen
ruhr-trainade dabei straßenflair in der
Jahrhunderthalle in Bochum die
Choreografin Mitte Ingwersen hat das
Stück mit belgischen Jugendlichen
zusammen entwickelt
als Skaterin die auf öffentlichen
Plätzen skated ist es komisch sich
plötzlich auf einer Bühne wiederzufinden
das ist Wahnsinn die Möglichkeit zu
bekommen hier aufzutreten ich bin sehr
froh darüber
die ruhrtrinale verbindet Hochkultur mit
urbaner Kunst gespielt wird in den
ehemaligen Industriestädten des
Ruhrgebiets 34 internationale
Inszenierungen spannen einen breiten
Bogen von Opa Schauspiel tanzt
Performance bis hin zu Lesungen und
Konzerten natürlich kann ein großes
Kultur und Kunstfestival in so einer
Region eben auch die unterschiedlichsten
Publikumsgruppen zusammenbringen und
Leute auch neugierig machen auf etwas
damit sie sich vielleicht noch gar nicht
beschäftigt haben eröffnet wurde das
Festival mit Shakespeares
Sommernachtstraum inszeniert von der
Intendantin persönlich ein Spiel
zwischen Traum und Wirklichkeit mit
Figuren die Halt im Leben suchen sich
nach Liebe sehnen ich flehe dich an und
das bekomme ich wenn ich
das tue eine Kirche in Duisburg wird in
eine begehbare Installation verwandelt
Kunst an ungewöhnlichen Orten auch dafür
steht die ruhefinale die bis Ende
September noch zu sehen sein wird
[Musik]
aber jetzt erstmal Fußball-WM Rudi die
ist immer wieder für Überraschung gut
genau jetzt im Viertelfinale gerade
passiert Spanien und Schweden haben als
erste Teams des Halbfinale bei der
Frauenfußball WM erreicht Spanien siegte
im Viertelfinale gegen die Niederlande
mit zwei zu eins Schweden setzte sich
überraschend gegen Ex-Weltmeister Japan
ebenfalls mit zwei zu eins durch
kein Trost trocknet ihre Tränen mit
Favorit Japan ist raus aus dem Turnier
und damit der letzte frühere WM
Titelträger die Schwedinnen taktisch
geschickt dazu mit den nötigen Glück als
jedes der Ball vor die Füße fällt die
Führung nach einer guten halben Stunde
einem klaren Handspiel folgt das 2:0 für
die Skandinavierinnen Angela nervenstark
und platziert
zu platzieren auf der Gegenseite der
vlfmeter für Japan uiki vergibt in der
Schlussviertelstunde bringt eine
ständige Belagerung des schwedischen
Tores nur noch den Anschluss Treffer
durch haiachi mehr aber nicht
überglückliche Schwedinnen zum fünften
Mal in einem WM Halbfinale Gegner am
Dienstag Spanien
Zusammenfassungen von allen Spielen
dieser WM finden Sie wie immer bei uns
in der ZDF heute App mit vier Spielen
beginnt heute die erste Runde des
DFB-Pokals alle Träume natürlich vom
Finale in Berlin Ende Mai heute Abend
bei uns in Sportstudio live Eintracht
Braunschweig gegen Schalke 04 beide aus
der Zweiten Liga Jochen Breyer in
Braunschweig was für einen Pokalabend
dürfen wir erwarten
einen sehr lauten das steht schon mal
fest die Fans von Eintracht Braunschweig
sie sind berüchtigt für ihren
Geräuschpegel sie haben sich heute
Mittag schon in der Innenstadt getroffen
25.000 werden heute hier sein und was
das ausmachen kann das haben wir letztes
Jahr in der ersten Pokalrunde gesehen da
kam ein Bundesligist Hertha BSC und ist
nach einem spektakulären 4:4 am Ende im
Elfmeterschießen schießen ausgeschieden
und es war die Hölle los hier im Stadion
auf genau so einen Abend hoffen wir auch
heute der Gegner heißt Schalke 04
Schalke ist auf dem Papier natürlich der
Favorit aber Schalke tritt nicht nur
gegen die Braunschweiger Mannschaft an
sondern eben auch gegen die Kulisse und
das kann sehr sehr spannend werden wir
melden uns um 20:15 Uhr wieder hier aus
Braunschweig alles klar Jochen vielen
Dank dann wünsche ich dir einen heißen
Pokal haben
der Hickhack um den Transfer von Harry
Kane zum FC Bayern München scheint noch
heute ein Ende zu nehmen der Stürmer von
Tottenham soll in München gelandet sein
und noch heute einen Medizincheck
absolvieren sein bisheriger Coach
erklärte vor dem Saisonauftakt in
England dass er nicht mehr mit ihm
planen Bayerns Trainer Thomas Tuchel
wollte heute noch nicht auf den
Millionen Wechsel eingehen
das war's dankeschön gerne wir bleiben
aber noch ein bisschen beim Spitzensport
es geht um einen neuen
Geschwindigkeitsrekord mit einem
Bobby-Car was wie ein normales Bobbycar
aussieht ist eine echte rennseme mit
Elektromotor und Hightech unter der
Haube der Student Marcel Paul fährt das
Bobbycar im Liegen und erreicht damit
auf dem Hockenheimring über
148 km pro Stunde das ist neuer Rekord
der gummiverschleiß bei den Bremsen ist
übrigens hoch denn gebremst wird
klassisch Bobby Car mäßig mit den Füßen
das Sommerwetter heute ist leider nur
von kurzer Dauer das Wochenende wird
zwar warm aber sehr wechselhaft mehr hat
gleich Katja horneffer Maria Slomka
begrüßt sie im heute journal in der
Halbzeitpause um 21:35 Uhr und wir
wünschen Ihnen ein richtig schönes
Wochenende bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend es hat zwar keine Namen aber
es hat es in sich nämlich Regenschauer
und Gewitter bringt dieses Tief mit das
morgen an der Westgrenze Deutschlands
weiter bis nach Dänemark zieht das mit
dem Schauern und kurzen Gewittern geht
schon heute Nacht los im Osten ist es
dagegen klar dort wird es auch am
kühlsten da sinken die Nachttemperaturen
auf 16 bis 12 Grad während es im Westen
schon deutlich Lauer bleibt bei 19 bis
16 Grad und morgen erwarten uns doch
fast überall Sommertemperaturen zwischen
25 Grad in der Lüneburger Heide und 31
Grad im Breisgau nur ganz im Norden und
ganz im Westen bleibt es etwas kühler am
längsten freundlich ist es morgen hier
in Berlin Brandenburg in Sachsen Bayern
und auch am Alpenrand sonst gibt es
viele Regenschauer und Gewitter und
diese Gewitter können auch
unwetterpotenzial haben das sind
Gewitter die mit hagelplatz Regen und
sturmhöhen verbunden sind solche
Gewitter gibt's am Sonntag auch
wahrscheinlich vor allen Dingen in
Baden-Württemberg und später auch in
Bayern Freund hier sieht's aus von der
Ostseeküste bis zur Mosel da werden sie
häufig die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen an
der Nordsee gibt es einige Regenschauer
und ähnlich wechselhaft geht es dann
noch Anfang der kommenden Woche weiter
guten Abend